oh this level cities [ __ ]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by the hood Pope
himself ASAP ferg you know I'm from
Smash Hits like work a new level his
streetwear brand trap Lord and you can
check out his latest project still
striving hot off the presses and
available now bird welcome to the show
sup man I was a little nervous coming
here
I ain't gonna lie that's not uncommon a
lot of people what's the headspace like
right now oh I got the glue everyone I'm
good keep it tight I'll give it a try
right there how are you without food I'm
pretty good I haven't ate hot food hot
hot food in a while oh my family is West
Indian so you know in Trinidad they make
like really hot pepper sauce but I left
a lot of that stuff alone when I was a
kid I just used to put it on my friends
when they were asleep you ready to get
going I'm ready to get it done
[Music]
all right so this first one is Valentin
a black label no tangle I want to start
with still striving because the third
time can you talk to me about Nando's is
it true that your bros you wrote Nando's
while eating Nando's on the PJ back from
Kon well I didn't write it on the PJ but
that was definitely a real experience
first time I was on a private jet I had
some Nando's waiting for me for the
uninitiated can you explain why Nando's
is such a big deal because between you
and post Malone and Kanye it really
seems to be gaining traction with the
rap elite when you go to UK or you go to
Europe and you flying overseas it's hard
to find good food so you can rely on
Nando's to give you some good chicken
[Music]
I'm not mad at these wings don't like it
got a good crisp to it right yeah we've
really stepped up our game you should
have seen us on season 1 really dusty
wings we had lots of complexions yeah so
like most everyone in ASAP mob your love
of fashion has been well-documented and
I know that you had dreams of being a
designer before the rap thing ever took
off so what I want to do is hit you with
some of the biggest 90s trends and
brands and I just want to bounce them
off of you and you can tell me which
ones are overrated which ones are
underrated which ones you think are due
for a comeback does that sound good
right Pelle Pelle yeah I mess with Pelle
Pelle can I say I [ __ ] with Pelle Pelle
you can't [ __ ] with Pelle Pelle Doc
Martens I see Doc Martin trying to sneak
his way back up in a I see playboy car
you win
and we'd be looking at him like this
sometime I don't know a lot of like that
no it could bounce this way it could
bounce yeah and no one knows like this
right now Mecca Mecca don't bring that
back no you need so regular like is your
wings the same thing as mine we can
switch the paddles if you want Ferg I'm
down for whatever you want to do but I
think it's just I've done this week over
week this is not my life the doodle must
be hot shit's hot hot this one tastes
like a tire so with ASAP mob you really
seem to be part of this growing
resurgence and rap where the crew is now
very much a real thing so I want to do
something a little bit different here I
want to hit you with a hypothetical so
close your eyes if you need to so I want
you to picture TDE ovo Odd Future an
ASAP mob gonna hit you with some
hypotheticals here okay
besides ASAP mob who would you put your
money on in a cypher to eat which crew
would put on the best fashion show this
em off you knew that one right away
little father's at his Fashion Issue if
you had to do a one-for-one trade with
one of these crews who would you poach
man it's hard they did some we pick can
we pick a girl go ahead and pick a girl
but I actually I see I say scissor
Kendrick and cube and then you got to
give up three you got to trade them all
right so they could have NASA his chip
two they could take a D and they could
take flaco ed stinking ass
this next one is the Queen Majesty it's
the scotch bonnet sauce oh you can
always yeah you can open your eyes look
a little label going with it you gotta
have your things you know so here at
first we feast were obsessed with the
chopped cheese so much so in fact that
we actually made a whole documentary
about it I heard about that
can you explain why it's such a Harlem
icon chopped cheese is a Harlem icon
because if no other restaurants is open
you can always rely on the corner store
that make your charm cheese what's your
go-to bodega sandwich if I want to get a
little funky with it get funky with yeah
I'm gonna get funky I'm gonna get jiggy
with it then I'll get a raisin bagel
toasted with egg whites and cheese
scramble egg white with cheese and a
turkey bacon and we lit it with a snap
speaking of Harlem icons do you [ __ ]
with nutcrackers yeah you been to the
mommy spot no no no yeah yeah no cracker
I definitely focus in nutcrackers
I'll be afraid of the sweetness because
I know it's gonna get terrible after
that there's a little sweetness up front
little heat in the back but not too much
is a little tingle verge it's the old
tingle for you little tingle all right
friggin Stein we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
Graham and what we do is we do a deep
dive on our guests Instagram we pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so I'll show you the picture and
then you just tell me the bigger story
does that sound good
cool are you doing so far I feel like
you're holding up pretty good I'm good I
kept thinking about Kevin Hart because
first and foremost I love this outfit
yeah evil FERC knieval at easy season
fire it was home inspired by touch the
sky video when Kanye would Evel
Knievel's outfit I remember Connie
talking to me for about an hour that was
as long as we ever really talk to each
other and he was just like man you so
fly man I feel underdressed like he like
the Evel Knievel wink but he didn't even
say nothing about it he just said you
fly my god I thought he would go deep he
was probably like oh I think I've seen
something like that yeah look good you
know he got so much digging moments he
probably doesn't remember exactly all
right up next a coogee down TVT coogee
down to the side like I'm biggie de
poblet I usually go to Catholic school
used to have to pay like a dollar to
wear regular clothes on certain days
that was my time I used to get fly so
our waters cool G I remember like this
girl I had a crush on her name is
Stephanie
it was just Dominican chick and she's
just like rubbing on my sleeves and all
of that light and all my teachers knew
what it was it is his parents got money
that's when you knew the power of high
fashion yeah exactly
right right all right so this next one
is dirty Dick's very aggressive brand
name dirty what Dick's paws
this is pretty good but you do like the
sauce yeah it's all just good pause I
thought about the name again i'ma have
to rip the tag off daddy take something
that sauce home alright so I want to
switch gears and talk about a time you
know before a hundred million roses
before the get high video and you and
ASAP Rocky were just a couple of
teenagers running around and Harlem
together when you think back on the
coming-of-age moments that you had
before you were famous so there any
stories that stand now Mia rock you met
just being in the street we was kind of
like pre famous before we we just called
it popping we was popping in Harlem it
was just clip called the rich girls that
used to feel like these boat rides
you know these didn't fight everybody
like if you was somebody in Harlem you
had to be there I seen him at a couple
boat rides and you gave each other fives
I knew some of his homies you know some
of mine and he heard that Iraq and he
respected my fashion so we kind of
linked up on that and we kind of came
together I started making music together
and that's when we formed ASAP well we
joined ASAP because a that was already
formed through yams what was like the
dream at that time was it a music dream
no it wasn't a music dream it was like a
group of kids that know about releases
of Margiela shoes and hanging out that
fashion parties and so hold yams is
always a person like a student of music
he wanted to take a stab at the music
thing and our projects and play music
together so yams is kind of the GM in
that whole equation yeah yams is is Yoda
in a situation
[Music]
south of the Flatbush zombies there you
go oh yeah this is when they get hot ice
no you know right OS melted ice melt the
pepper sauce yo you gangsta bird this is
hot I'm gonna come clean it's like on
this side it's not even on both sides
it's just this side that's ringing it's
it's wherever it catches you Diggs India
is whining right not in the molars or
whatever and it just this year is lit my
lips are starting to tingle right now
this is not mm-hmm moment of no return
all right don't don't rub your eyes
don't rub your eyes so I want to talk to
about music videos for a second because
I know that you take great pride in the
visuals and you seem to be inspired by
90s era directors like hype Williams and
I wonder in this internet age we have
this proliferation and productions
cheaper do you think that that's
birthing a new golden age for music
videos or do you think that music videos
are getting worse and worse I think it's
getting worse and better at the same
time you have a lot of kids that's
taking their their stab at it which is a
great thing but it's a rack of videos
that's whack you know because they just
learned how to shoot videos they never
went to school for it and I trained for
it what if you had a Jay Z Big Pimpin
but my budget I'm gonna shoot a few
movies that's what I'm gon do yeah we
going to the Oscars with that word
[Music]
let's see what this is about
this is the bomb beyond insanity oh it
smells different it smells different
[Music]
you know right away it was a piece of
that [ __ ] that just hit the back of the
throat this down you don't want to be no
there's levels to this [ __ ]
[Music]
nah I'm not chewing this I just gonna
sit down
the old milk chaser strategy milk
probably make it worse
low-key there it is there it is you good
my head is starting to tingle
that's a brilliant segue Ferg because
you know given your larger news to give
in your country
you got it you got it man so given your
fashion choice today and given the
number of do-rag cameos that I see on
your Instagram I think it's safe to say
that you're one of the biggest do-rag
fanatics and hip-hop right now so what I
want to do they get us down bounce some
other icons of the genre some other
do-rag icons off of you and I want to
see the looks that you like the ones you
don't like as much and maybe you can
rank them and we'll just go from there
does that sound good all right laptop
like crying right now it happens it
happened OSes run it
[Music]
like a kid first up we had to start here
Nellie Nellie definitely had a good
do-rags you started going fades on us we
said we sort of do rags less and less
the more country he went the more fades
he went to do rag Club kind of lost like
grass roots a little bit yes you guys
stop sending him the newsletters and
exactly Nellie
all right up next Eminem yeah he had to
do rag era yeah that's funny
cuz I don't know white people could get
ways and he'd have like Carolina blue
one on otherwise is winner to go is
outfit right my lips feel swollen now by
the way
now Coolio has a because he'd go antlers
out man he go antlers out everywhere I
seen him in an airport and all he has is
the antlers now he has a boy head with
just the braids now I'm gonna I guess
them stand up like that and he's talking
to aliens with those things a little
more bandana yeah
but Bret Michaels at Michaels yeah
that's cool that's what he does I always
wonder what what it was like under that
I used to watch his show and I always
wonder what his hairline with it's got
to be worse than mine that's why he has
it you got like a little and you got
like a little Mirage happening right now
the way the light hits it I'm not like a
sting thing happening right now
thank you for yeah ja Rule so you used
to leave it completely undone as a fresh
brand new direct out the pack
whatever red carpet he was on you
probably left the the package right on
the floor because you could see the
creases in a do-rag right there but his
his string sits untouched
he didn't even tie that ever you just do
it over the head good luck bad luck what
do you think of that [ __ ] with that look
I don't got one more for ya spooky black
spooky black focus will get black
yeah [ __ ] with him yeah I like that look
I like that look well who's the king
who's the king of do-rag Mountain I'm
the king of do-rag Mountain ja rule a
second
is spooky black history bronze medal for
spooky black yeah shouts spooky black
I'm serious this whole side of my lips
is like blisters this happening right
now yeah yeah what happens so this is
Blair's Megadeth sauce with liquid rage
yeah I just I thought it was gone no no
I already know I'm scared to lick the
top of my teeth no you start to smell it
first and then you kind of get in your
huddle don't let my I'm gonna explain
what it is right now so the viewers know
what's happening my eyes is tearing
right now my lip that feels like it's
been burned by a cold on this whole side
right here
so I started and um up every time I'm
it's hard for me to talk a little bit
because my throat is burning right now
mm-hmm mm-hmm and every time I swallow I
get another head of it
so you've collaborated with such an
extreme range of artists from ariana
grande and Madonna to Missy Elliott even
touring with Skrillex who was the most
fun who turned the studio into a party I
was a Skrillex because Skrillex I was at
his house in LA you know relax he had
Diplo there too
I don't know where it was like cannibal
the the comedian is a cannibal Hannibal
Burres Hannibal get Hannibal and I'm he
was drunk as [ __ ] Katy Perry walked in
out of nowhere and he throws that being
on which is hungry and and Diplo starts
to rap on it and Hannibal starts to rap
on it too and then this dude Skrillex
Sonny he started to do ad libs on like
Diplo's tracks and stuff like that so I
got a version of all of those guys
sorry I can't talk right now because my
mouth is burning but I got a version of
all of them on the track and I gotta see
if he still has that I may put it out
would you learn the most from Diddy and
I was just watching them in speakings
one who had the place decked out in
aromatherapy candles and Persian rugs
who's the who's the big five person
that's Madonna yeah I went to own the
jungle studios she had candles and was
asking me if I wanted its tea she was
knowing all of this while she had grills
on her mouth
yeah and when I pulled up she had all
her lyrics like printed out on a sheet
of paper total Pro yeah it was dope yo
who would you choose crazy what's crazy
it comes back you think is gone but it
pulls up that's the thing you just did
it to me that's the thing about hot
sauce you know it's just like it's
always chasing and it's like the back of
the tongue right now mm-hmm
you know you catch a lake or something I
start tearing up all right well what
that is a segue nah that's jello why is
this one yellow this is the last dab
it's a tough one and it's tradition to
put a little dab on the last wing it's
enough dabs on this you don't have to if
you don't want to burn the dab is played
out now nobody's dabbing no more you did
it somebody do it my lips is still
burning
yeah that's you know other guess we've
had them do a little schmear action you
can kind of control it a little bit more
that's smart that's a veteran move
that's a veteran move
and hopefully with just like this
alright for my man Cheers
[Music]
nah this is our say I smell it already
flavor taste it you know oh this is
sneaky
it's just sneaky little bastard right
here and then the wave comes out yeah oh
yo
that right there is a sneaky bastard
that should have been the tagline I may
get a little light-headed when I stand
up and my lip tango a mm-hmm that one is
rocking me still you know I don't ever
want to meet that again one more
question for you Ferg
so you're an accomplished artist one of
the hottest rappers in the game but I
know that deep down you're still a cozy
boy at heart when you're done prospering
when you're done striving I know that
you just really want to settle into the
couch with some Netflix so while the
last dab is hitting on you and coming up
can you recommend a show for the people
out there what is ASAP ferg binge
watching right now I Defiant ones if
you're a musician and you love music you
will love that for episodes i watch all
of them and I watch them Matt Tom's it's
secure how'd you start watching that
which is a dope shower of course right
that's every Sun shadow Simona though
she's making it brilliantly this is
[ __ ] television oh I have another
favorite show
as nuts and bolts fights cartoons of
that show Jim Henson claymation all that
I'm a sports guy I like to go to the
events
I don't really catch it on TV like that
because I'm just always traveling I met
LeBron actually um in Toronto for
Caribana and uh
he's cool he came oh it just hit me
Ferg you made it through you watch a lot
of TV and you can crush some chicken
wings now there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you for this
camera this camera or this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life
i immense dose driving out now I was
traveling for so long all year long that
when I came home I just wanted to excuse
to hang out with my friends and make
dope music so that's what you were
healing a project so shadow said
everybody doing it shout out to you for
being a G and home introducing me to all
of these hot sauces you got too much
sauces official way too much sauce a lot
of sauce a set
[Applause]
yeah I say if you can make a milk
mustache but you don't probably do maybe
a ward after yeah hello hot ones fans
its Sean Evans new outro same message if
you like what just saw throw us a bone
maybe please it is dog-eat-dog here on
the YouTube streets hit that subscribe
button
knowing that you subscribed it is
seriously the only thing that gets me
out of bed in the morning
thank you very much hot ones fans I love
you